John Mayer reveals new music is coming  very very soon et was with the musician  and the john mayer trio at the jazz  foundation of america's annual gala  benefiting elder jazz and blues  musicians when the trio's drummer steve  jordan revealed the name of john's next  album by accident when we first came  together we're tsunami relief we were  starting the continuum album and so now  we're doing this relief and it's in the  middle of finishing John's newest album  the search for everything John's newest  album the search for everything actually  that's the first time steve is a diva's  announced the record now it's white the  name of the record twice and I have not  told anybody oh oops he just told her  now but when pressed on what the first  single would be called John wouldn't  spill only teasing us with when it might  drop yeah yeah very soon very very  graciously within days we are within it  within wheat in the weeks of a very  scant number of weeks bring it on John